at this altitude I can run flat-out for
my this episode is brought to you by
helix sleep last year I committed to
making sleep a top priority trying to
fix onset insomnia or continuing to fix
that depth of sleep quality of sleep I
tracked a lot I tested a lot and I
revisited really everything from the
daily routine to the surfaces I slept on
playing with a chili pad whatever and
when I moved to Austin I got all new
beds including mattresses from helix
working with the world's leading sleep
expert certainly some of them helix
sleep developed mattresses personalized
to your preferences and sleep style to
make sure that you can have the best
sleep possible without costing thousands
upon thousands of dollars helix sleep
has recently added a new layer to
customize sleep with the helix pillow
the all new pillows are fully adjustable
so you can achieve perfect comfort
regardless of a sleep position or body
type or if you're a shifty type like me
I move around quite a bit when I sleep
just take their simple two to
three-minute sleep quiz to get started
and that will help ensure that they can
build a mattress or pillow that you will
love the mattress
whatever this bespoke mattress is that
you arrive at will get to you within a
week and the shipping is completely free
you can try the mattress for 100 nights
and if you're not completely happy
they'll pick it up and offer a full
refund I tested that refund policy
because I test all of these sponsors and
kick the tires a lot we tested it and
they came through on making sure that we
got ultimately the right mattress for my
body type to personalize your sleep
experience visit helix sleep calm
forward-slash Tim and you'll receive up
to 125 dollars off your mattress order
that's helix sleep hgl is sleep calm
forward-slash tim for up to 125 dollars
off your order
this episode is brought to you by
business Wars people always ask me what
podcasts I listen to and the truth is
not many because given all my other
projects I don't have a ton of extra
bandwidth but one new addition is
business warrants from the podcast
network one during human history has
seen hundreds upon hundreds of epic wars
of course and often there between
nations but some wars are waged between
large corporations are between startups
and large incumbents business wars which
have been listening to teach you right
into the middle of these battles that
are waged for control of your wallet and
your attention ranging from say the wars
between Netflix and blockbuster or Nike
and Adidas to rivals and small
businesses across the country struggling
to survive in a cutthroat world these
stories really feel like dramatic
thrillers I've been very impressed by
the sound design also which I didn't
think I would care about but it makes a
huge huge difference and just to give
you an idea of what you might discover
did you know that blockbuster was
actually catching up with Netflix until
corporate raider Carl Icahn got involved
and that episode is a fantastic one it's
called sudden death it's the first
episode in a multi-part a series that
looks at Blockbuster and Netflix which
I'm particularly interested in because
it's not just to businesses in a
stagnant industry with stagnant
technology there's a lot of different
factors that come into play or did you
know or do you know what Marvel did to
really get ahead of its much larger
competitor DC Comics of great interest
to me since I was a comic book nerd and
collected comics when I was a kid or how
sneakers went from athletic wear to
everyday wear this series explores all
of that and more it's hosted by David
Brown a former anchor of marketplace and
it is an immersive sound design
experience not just some type of sterile
business review that shares the untold
and very real stories of what went on
behind the scenes with the leaders
investors executives that led them to
either new heights or to ruin sometimes
somewhere in between you can search for
business words on Apple podcasts
wherever you're listening to this
episode right now or head to wonder e
dot FM 4 / Tim that's wo NT er y FM
forward slash Tim to find the
it's a great show and I do not say that
lightly and I might suggest start with
sudden death
Netflix versus blockbuster hello ladies
and gentlemen this is Tim Ferriss and
welcome to another episode of the Tim
Ferriss show my job is usually to
deconstruct world-class performers from
different industries and sectors
military entertainment business and so
on to tease out habits and routines from
people who have made seemingly all of
the right decisions this episode is very
different and my hope is that it still
provides learning lessons and takeaways
and helps you also to develop skills
like empathy this came about because I
interviewed a woman named Kat Hoch on
this podcast she is the founder of
something called defy ventures which
uses entrepreneurship and job training
to reduce recidivism among prison
populations and she creates what she
would call entrepreneurs in training ee
i ee s and inmates if you want to call
them that are encouraged to use this as
a new label for self-identification and
it's been very very successful when I
spoke to her on this podcast I promised
that I would visit a prison with her and
that's exactly what I ended up doing
several weeks ago I visited a
maximum-security prison to experience
the program that she started I struggled
with trying to do this introduction
several times so I'm just gonna run with
it and it's going to perhaps bounce
around a bit it was a very very
emotional trip and I thought I would
actually borrow from my friend dr. Peter
Tia who also attended and recruited a
number of people to go alongside him and
he sent this out to his newsletter and
I'm gonna abridge a little bit this week
Tim Ferriss and I recruited a few
friends to visit kern state prison krn
level 4 IE max security prison in
california and the background then goes
in to how to 5 entries done work inside
prisons like kern in Pelican Bay he goes
on to say Kat is one of the most
remarkable Souls in this planet nothing
could prepare me for what we experienced
a current Rai to explain in an email
eventually discuss
this in-depth on a podcast and these are
Peters words again many of the men came
up to us as we were leaving with tears
in their eyes to thank us for coming and
to express their gratitude for the
little bit we did but I don't think they
will ever understand is that they gave
us infinitely more than we can give them
I cannot explain with words when it
feels like to embrace a 32 year old man
who has been incarcerated since he was
13 in solitary confinement for 12 of
those years and admit our most shameful
moments in life to each other so some of
you might be listening to this back to
Tim now and wondering what the hell is
Tim talking about and I'm gonna use a
statistic that I've heard several times
someone out there can fact check this
but I believe it's accurate which is
roughly 70 percent of people released
from maximum-security prisons are back
in prison within five years and this
underscores a number of weaknesses and
issues with number of societal systems
that we've put in place but suffice to
say many of the people who are even
convicted of murder are going to be
released they're going to be your
neighbors and there is a choice then
rather than just brushing it aside with
they should just lock them up and throw
away the key since that's not going to
be the case for many folks there's a
question of whether you want people to
be rehabilitated or not which type of
neighbor having just come out of prison
do you want to have and there's much
more nuance to it but that's one helpful
has to lead into it and I began looking
at programs with good results and unique
approaches to helping to fundamentally
change how people view themselves and
the world and that is part of what I try
to do and I learned so much at Kern that
I wanted to dig into it with this
podcast but also to share with you the
the footage the audio footage that I
recorded from the rare opportunity to
actually sit down with three men on the
inside and to talk to them about the
mistakes they've made when they turn
things around
what they've done when they slip up and
so on and it applies to much more
than people in prison or people who have
committed homicide or armed robbery I
think it applies to everybody so I
wanted to really paint a picture of the
humanity and people who have done
terrible things no doubt about it they
have suffered the consequences per the
rules that we have in the societies that
we've built and are now attempting and
changing their trajectories and we all
have these different points in life when
it's important to change direction so I
owe a special thanks first and foremost
to all the staff and officers occur in
including chief deputy Warren Goss who
helped set up the interview keeping in
mind I couldn't even bring in an
alligator clip because to hold pieces of
paper together because those can be
fashioned into tools for cutting through
doors I'm not making this up so to have
the ability to walk in with cables and
recorders and all this was really really
incredible and unique again I knew I was
gonna struggle this intro
but I'm never gonna get it quite right
and I wanted to at least explain one
exercise we did which will come back to
Peters words that was so incredibly
powerful speaking to a number of the
volunteers like me who were there to
help as mentors listening to different
pitches for new businesses and so on
that these men hope to launch when they
get out of prison to sustain them the
vast majority of volunteers I spoke with
said it was one of the most emotionally
powerful experiences of their entire
lives and I'm gonna quote from a Fast
Company piece that covered defy and
describes an exercise called step to the
line which if you have the opportunity
to experience I highly highly recommend
I cannot recommend it highly enough in
fact so here we go I'm quoting from the
piece quote the idea is this remember
exercise step to the line Hoke let's cat
reads from a list of statements and if
they ring true to any of the EITS ie the
inmates or volunteers they step forward
to the line and so there are two lines
of tape on the ground about say 18
inches apart and they run for 20 to 30
feet maybe more because you could have
say 50 to 100 e aí T's and similar
number of volunteers
all right back to the piece she'll
eventually read several dozen of the
statements and the group that steps to
the line each time is different
all right this piece took place or was
reported at Pelican Bay I'm gonna cut
some of it out so she begins with
statements designed to loosen folks up I
was a class clown people step forward or
not
I'm madly in love I'm madly in love with
burritos ha ha ha so people loosen up
and this is important in any type of
exercise or interview then she moves on
to the harder stuff I've had my heart
broken again this is from a fast comedy
piece everyone in the room steps to the
line except one AIT I dropped out of
high school almost every EIT steps
forward with just one of the volunteers
I've been in a fight to prove myself all
but three of the EIT is move forward and
then it's time for the really deep stuff
I grew up in poverty my mom or dad has
been to prison at least one of my
parents abused drugs or alcohol I was
born through a teenage mother I became a
teenage parent myself these are all
separate questions and people step to
the line or step back from the line and
pulling back just for a second to my
experience there were other questions
that really were a kind of a donkey kick
to the psyche because they were
considerations I'd never made before
such as and I'm paraphrasing here but I
grew up in a home with fewer than 25
books out of the volunteers everyone
stepped forward to the line of the EITS
two or three right right back to the
piece watching hook in the EITS you
begin to understand the life stories of
the people in the room just by how many
steps of line or how many did so again
and again
my parents tuck me into bed and told me
I was loved a few of the EIT step
forward violence took place in my home
growing up violence took place against
me growing up when I was 18 I thought I
wouldn't make it to 21 and it goes on
and on not forgiving others is hurting
me and almost everybody is gonna step
forward at least during my experience
that was the case and there are others
such as have you ever sat behind the
wheel of the car while feeling the
effects of alcohol almost everybody's
going to step forward and then I have
been convicted of driving while drunk
and so on and so forth and then you see
how circumstances certainly freewill and
bad decision but also sir
stances have led us all to where we are
and that doesn't absolve anybody in
prison of the things that they did but
it does give you an appreciation for how
things could have turned out differently
had a handful of circumstances been
different for even the volunteers and I
know this intro is running long please
bear with me
so this interview talking with these
three men was really profound experience
for me and you can see the hope in these
men that is created when they have an
opportunity to rebuild and redefine
themselves I was very very impressed and
surprised by a lot of what I saw some
incredible artwork and some incredibly
well-spoken people and when they take
ownership of their pasts and are going
to be getting out of prison the question
comes back to yet again who do you want
back in society rehabilitated person or
not I'm going to mention two more things
and were going to jump into the
interview if people want to go to prison
and have this type of experience cat is
still bringing people and now has five
more prison trips lined up you can email
admin at cat hakam CA th oke comm if
interested there are also other groups
doing this type of work and making an
impact like the anti-recidivism
coalition AR c you can find that at
anti-recidivism dot org and i wanted to
just mention one more thing and this was
sent to me which is quite difficult
through i'm imagining two or three
different intermediaries by one of the
men who i interviewed for this podcast
and it was a follow up on one of the
questions that I had sent so this is a
message from Jason who was interviewed
and this is what he sent through the
proper channels to get to me quote
during the interview Tim asked us a very
important question that we feel was
perhaps the most important one of all he
asked how we handle setbacks or slip-ups
and what we tell people who make
mistakes along the way I felt like this
was something that merited at least
reaching out for if there's a way to
include this that would be cool if not I
tried it is unrealistic to think that a
person could make drastic changes in
their life in charter new
trajectory and then execute without
failure two steps forward one step back
is not uncommon to that I've told others
and still say that the key lies in not
allowing oneself to become discouraged
to the point of a total regression note
the failure simply as a result that
didn't get you to your objective and
then tweak your strategy accordingly try
try again it is often stated that those
who are most successful in life are also
really good at dealing with failure we
should use them as role models and view
it as they do
it's simply feedback that we can use to
discern how our plan is working this is
easier said than done but it's been done
many times over good luck and take heart
because the best is yet to come so this
is what Jason would say to someone who
has back slit and that could be say
you're trying to lose weight and then
you end up eating a box of cookies it
could be that you quit smoking and you
have a few drinks and much to your later
regret and shame that you pick up a
cigarette it could be any number of
things but you'll find a lot of shared
humanity in this conversation and there
are a few quick notes the shoe is
solitary confinement we initially only
had 20 minutes allowed for this and then
there was a bus malfunction for another
group arriving so I was able to stretch
it out quite a bit I also realized after
the fact that I shouldn't have asked
about specific gang names because there
can be violent consequences so I bleeped
out one mention of that and with that
very very long introduction out of the
way thank you guys for the patience
please enjoy this conversation a very
rare opportunity behind the wall in a
maximum-security prison to chat with
three men about their life stories
alright guys so we're sitting here in
the this the visitation center sitting
that what looks like a I guess a a
half-circle table and it's my first time
in a prison and we are in a
maximum-security prison and I was hoping
maybe we could start I know time is
short just on a quick round of
introductions just one at a time saying
name it could be first name full name
and where you're from and how you ended
up in prison my name is Jason Holland 41
years old when I was a teenager I was
living a reckless life misguided youth
or actually I should say wayward youth
because I had to take responsibility for
my actions but um I was making some
decisions that clearly weren't good in
my life and eventually it resulted in me
taking someone's life and at 19 I was
sentenced to life without for parole for
a felony murder and I've been in prison
ever since thank you yes sir Tim welcome
to prison thank you my name is Ian Viet
Oro I'm 37 years old I've been
incarcerated for the past ten years I am
serving a sentence for two counts of
armed robbery firearm deadly weapon
unfortunately I went through a really
bad divorce in 2006 I think that was
perhaps the the significant event that
kind of led me here
I didn't cope well in fact I made all
the right wrong decisions and I made
some very poor choices obviously I
gravitated back to you know the crowd
that I used to run with when I was much
much younger and I'm here now and uh
kind of trying I'm trying to trying to
make the best of of Who I am now
basically my name is Brandon when I was
21 I was incarcerated for murder I'm
serving life without parole when I was
younger I had some real issues socially
reacting interacting with people it
caused me to sort of compartmentalize my
life among groups of people and it took
an enormous amount of emotional energy
to uphold that
and as it started to fall apart and I
became desperate to latch on to these
people that led me to make some really
really bad choices and as a result I've
been incarcerated for the last 13 years
in May thank you guys so I mean the
question really in my mind is I'm
getting educated here it's my first time
like I mentioned kind of on the other
side of the walls is what what were the
the moments or the conversations that
led you guys to want to start building
in a different direction right because
there are a lot of people here don't
choose to change the path right and
there's just recently some violence here
and I understand the politics and sort
of gang orders and so on here can be
really complex I don't even pretend to
understand it but like in in in your
cases you've chosen to try to build in a
different direction so maybe we could
just go whoever wants to go first
could just let me know what catalyzed
that okay that's a very good question um
I had been incarcerated for about 19
years I was validated in the shoe as a
shoes that's the lockdown units a
security housing unit right and I was
validated as a prison gang associate at
that point I was housed in a deep seg
section what gang were you part of I was
associated with and in prison in this
world I had a lot of prestige I had a
lot of power and after 19 years I was
sitting in their shoe and I realized
even though I had this much prestige in
this much power I was living an empty
life it was meaningless and that was
isolation were you by yourself yes I was
by myself at that point and
one day a friend came to me and he was
telling me about changes that were
happening in the law and he said look if
you ever want to get out of the Shu you
need to start making some decisions and
I didn't want to take ownership of my
life at the time and so I was arguing
with them I was blaming everyone else
and then he said something that I
couldn't argue with he said look whether
you realize it or not to your own
decisions or decisions that you've
allowed people to make for you you put
yourself in a box and at that point I
couldn't argue with that and so I had to
come to terms with that and I had to
start making some real decisions and
that was a big moment for me and that
was a friend on the inside here no that
was actually a friend from the outside
mmm yes and he kind of hit it he hit me
with the hard truth and then I started
realizing what do I want from a life
where I started asking myself those
strong questions and I had to start
making some strong decisions and from
there it's been a path of growth what
were what were some of the firsts or the
first kind of decision that you made
that was different from how you would
have made decisions in the past well
first I had to start taking
responsibility I had to start realizing
that I was the one that was creating my
circumstances there was no one else and
then if I wanted to change things in my
life what were the decisions I had to
make and so the first thing I needed to
do was just get away from what I'd been
accepting for myself and that's being
involved with gangs and criminal
activities and so once I disassociated
and left and it was from there what do I
do now
right it was just a matter of
reconstructing my identity and finding
new values and at that point when you
left the gang you then moved from one
section of was it at this prison know as
a different prison didn't Corcoran got
it and where you then you were moved to
a different location within the prison
or was to a different unit for people
that were going through that process got
it like yes
so for me
God would I guess what I can I can start
in 2013 back then I was a member of a
prison gang here and for the most part
you know I've throughout my prison
career as we call it assimilated
completely in my environment I which
gang was that I'd rather not say yeah
okay yeah uh it's I was part of the
problem here yeah clearly and I remember
I think the moment that kind of changed
everything changed for me was I was
assigned to education and I mean
education just regular a B 1 a B 2 a B 3
just regular Adult Basic Education
I was I was assigned there so that I can
eventually earn my GED yeah and I you
know sitting in the back doing all the
things that I shouldn't be doing with
the homies and I just I felt I got tired
of it and I just didn't want to be there
anymore I had you know two ways of going
about it to get out of education at
least that's what I thought at the time
there was actually a third way I decided
to just take the GED test and that way I
would be able to get out of there and
that's exactly what I did I took the GED
test and I passed it I showed up about
two months later I got called up to
receive my certificate and while I was
standing in line waiting to get my
certificate somebody who was ahead of me
made a comment about you know now going
to college because you know now he would
he had a GED he was a high school
graduate and he was gonna go to college
but the way that he said he was being
sarcastic but he said it in a way where
someone in the room turned around and
looked at him with like this look of
disgust disbelief and it just so
happened that at that precise moment he
turned and looked at me and I caught the
full force of that look and that disgust
and it angered me because back then my
mentality was completely different and I
kind of set out to prove from that point
forward that you know what look at me
how you want to look at me but I'm gonna
prove to you that even a gang member
even someone like me can get a college
education
back then the college programs were very
very scarce it took a moment for me to
took a little while for me to even find
you know the college coordinator on the
facility and I wrote a couple community
colleges eventually they wrote back I
got I got it I got into a into lassen
Community College up north and I started
taking correspondence courses and so
here I am I'm sitting in a housing unit
filled with all my homeys because here
in this facility they house all the gang
members together just to kind of control
the violence on the yard and you know
after the first year here I am you know
knee-deep in college work studying
sociology psychology philosophy and just
you know really taking it on and one day
I just kind of looked up and I realized
I don't belong here I was completely out
of place meaning in the gang of iron in
the gang environment and you know for
the first time I was able to kind of see
the world through a clear lens so for me
it was definitely education and that was
five years five years now and I've
learned several college degrees and you
know it's it's I can honestly say that
education truly transformed me I was
still stuck there and it took someone in
the administration to give me an
opportunity to change to really make
that transition into who I wanted to be
associate warden Goss who's at the time
was the captain on our facility he gave
me that opportunity so it wasn't just me
wanting to I needed that help
and fortunately I was able to find that
here and you know I've it's been a
sprint since and I haven't stopped thank
you well so I'm kind of the odd man out
in a lot of ways all right so I was
never in a gang I came in and I was the
guy who was going to be used up on the
mainline I was the guy they were gonna
give the knife and say hey go get that
guy what is used up on the mainland I'd
pretty much means that I was expected to
do the dirty work as it needed to be
done and then when I was caught up and
washed up and done and done in or
whatever nobody was gonna really worry
about it too much because I wasn't in
the mix you know I wasn't in that whole
politic side so
I did that exactly once can you just
elaborate on what that means so guy came
up to me on the yard and he basically
said hey this guy we need to jump on him
because he owes money and I tried to get
out of it but I really didn't have a lot
of options because they said we're doing
this in about two minutes I got it
you're like a free agent I was a I was
not a free agent
while you were associated health no
matter what yeah I was I was a free
agent who was told you're gonna do this
so I did it it was it was cowardly I
hate it right but I did it and I ended
up in doing a shoot erm like Jason but
much shorter right and he in here I got
out I came to another lie
mainline yard and they asked me to do it
again and I said no we're not doing that
so they jumped on me instead so that was
fun I came over here to s my that's the
when you're not associating with the
mainland politics so I just kind of
figured I would fly under the radar
we're just gonna do my own thing on my
own by myself and slowly but surely just
started to get into a couple things get
talked to certain people work I wrote a
pickle for our newsletter things like
that and it eventually led to me getting
offered a job in the chapel which if
you'd have told me when I was say 21
that I'd be working in a chapel the
answer would have been zero because I
was 21 and knew everything and was this
militant atheist and blah blah blah so
the idea was absolutely unheard of but I
was really desperate for something I
needed to have something to do so I took
the job and I remember having a
conversation with my boss chaplain
Krantz our shout out to the you know the
chaplain and he sits me down and he
basically says so tell me tell me about
how you look at things so I gave him
this really profound like 30 minute
conversation about how I knew everything
and everything was relative and this and
that and I might be paraphrasing this
but he basically sits back and he goes
wow that's really stupid and I reflected
on that for awhile and he started to
systematically over the next few months
just like break down every stupid little
belief I had and slowly but surely
started to turn me around so I give him
a lot of credit
for me kind of going positive as it were
and kept kept pause for what sure what
were some of the new beliefs that that
ended up being most helpful to you the
biggest thing the biggest teaching that
he gave me was the theory of teleology
teleost right so all people have an
inherent human dignity everybody has a
potential and if everybody has this
dignity in this potential that everybody
is valuable every human life is valuable
we should treat them so so this was the
basis of a morality that I never had
everything I thought was relative if
it's good for me it's good for me it's
good for you it's good for you
and that's a bunch of crap that doesn't
work that leads to a very bad place so
this whole concept now and really
driving at home and it was it's been 16
months in the making so far but that for
me has been the pivotal thing is just
understanding concepts of morality going
from an atheist to a guy who's somewhat
of an auto agnostic who acknowledges
there's a higher power but doesn't know
what it is yet
so for me that's a huge shift and so I
credit that to me getting into the
things that I recognize is enforcing
morality or enforcing human dignity and
the idea that everybody is valuable
thank you I'd love to hear from you
Jason basically the same question I mean
like how has the way you looked at the
world changed or what beliefs or habits
have really helped to keep you on a
better path or to help you to feel like
you're building towards something okay
very good question so when I first left
the shoe and I was going through this
process of basically reconstructing my
identity because I had this persona
before and now it's gone right you had
status - yeah I did and so I come over
here and I didn't really know what to do
I started reinvesting in my education
because I didn't know really what to do
I started getting into these groups and
then what happened was I was really
lucky I came to this yard and I met
these guys and I started working around
them and then I started getting
introduced to this some of the same
ideas so how did you get to meet dignity
yeah well it was just kind of on the
yard but they knew I was coming
my brother and I were coming here and so
we kind of make a splash where we go and
we got introduced one way or another and
eventually I started working with them
and I saw what they were doing what they
were doing it with the program in the
Pioneer and all these different things
these interesting things and at this
point I started changing my my whole
perspective around and mostly the
biggest thing for me was I knew that if
I wanted I knew what I didn't want and I
knew I had to get rid of criminality out
of my mindset I knew I had to get stop
cutting corners and then like I said
when I started working with Tammy and
started getting introduced the idea that
of human dignity
so human dignity doing things in the
right way not doing in them in a
criminal way and from there my whole
perception started changing on how I
approach people how I approach
situations how I identify options to
solving challenges and problems finding
tools seeking out mentors things like
that so that's basically and it's it's
still an ongoing process so it sounds
like the three of you spending time
together as I mean I maybe I'm taking it
just got a one-degree further than what
I'm hearing but it seems like that's
been important absolutely crucial yeah
absolutely it's we're a team here we've
kind of you know through all the things
that we've been able to accomplish here
on this facility we've been able to kind
of form a community of sorts and it's
it's really a team effort upfront I know
that for me you know even the whole
change process you know it was a process
but I had to first come to that
realization that I can do better that I
could be better I had to accept it and I
had to believe it and that's what we try
to get guys to do on the facility on the
yard is believe it you know believe in
yourself believe that you can be better
you can do better you convinced them of
that it's like when you approach
somebody for the first time a how do you
choose the person you approach and then
what do you say and I mean anybody can
can hop in it takes one of the one of
the things is is being in the right
place at the right time we have self
taught and picked up and questioned
other people about everything from
effective communication techniques to
ways of getting people over twisted
values I mean
you guys do it because I'm speaking for
myself just because I'm a masochist and
it needs to be done yeah when I look out
at some people here or anywhere else for
that matter you watch the news you watch
TV any of it it just sometimes feels
like people are skin and bones
you know there's they need some they
need to be fleshed out a little you know
and me too you know I'm I'm just as bad
but I think that it's it's a communal
thing everybody needs to be pitching in
because nobody no man is an island yeah
so we just need to be there we need to
be available we need to be intentional
we need to really try to help everybody
elevate themselves because if we
humanize everyone we humanize ourselves
and if we cut people down we're just
cutting ourselves down to it and it
applies here in on steroids well it
seems like everything is magnified here
it things are a lot more intensified
it's a lot more potent here at least in
my opinion because everybody here's a
little extreme in some ways yeah you
never know that's the thing you never
know who it's gonna be where the light
bulbs gonna click or it's gonna go on
you just one day we could be working on
a guy for a year just trying to have the
right exchanges and interactions with
them and one day he just gets it or is
another guy we could think he's making
progress and then something happens and
also to come in and try to help them and
see what happened what are some of the
approaches or expressions or concepts
that you've seen help redirect people
like when you see people click and any
of you could jump like this I think I
think the biggest thing and for me it's
I've been there so I know what it feels
like to not have hope and you have
purpose all right there are a lot of
guys in here who are lacking those two
things and I know what it feels like
hope and purpose and there that's very
very powerful and that's what we try to
give them that you know we try to give
them a dose of purpose you know whether
it's through some sort of program or
whether it's just on one on one
interaction we'll write the program
like well just for example defy yeah the
five ventures has been amazing on this
facility because it's it's a holistic
more holistic it takes a holistic
approach it's not just entrepreneurship
training it's right it teaches character
development it brings you closer to your
family and it really gets you thinking
about who you are and who you can be
most importantly and it's it's it's been
hugely successful here because of it I
would add into empowerment you know
because I think a lot of the guys that
we interact with and myself included for
a long time I just didn't recognize my
potential or think that I really had any
worth investing in and I think that a
lot of these guys feel that way and a
big part of what we do is we engage that
and we challenge them to look at their
potential and actually rise to it and I
think that we do that to best that we
can that we're currently able to do and
we're trying to get better at it thank
you I think when you're I mean the
standard approach like on the like
institutionalized kind of formal level
of any of these things is your program
that you would have defi pay any of
these groups you have content some sort
of accredited content alright so there's
a curriculum there's a book if there's a
time honor there's 12 steps Oxford
principles you have a dosage rate these
guys will go to this group for X number
of hours every week over a course of a
year that's X number of hours and then
you have motivation and you get a result
and the result could be something like
22 percent reduction in recidivism for
substance abuse or something right yeah
the trick is the the hard one to
quantify is the motivation right right
so that's where the hope and the purpose
come in because a guy can sit in a chair
all day long a guy can answer questions
on a worksheet all day long but unless
he has the hope unless he has the need
for a purpose unless he has the family
begging him to get better unless he has
his buddy that he's watched move on and
his now it's like waiting for him to
catch up right you need to create this
sense of people that you can rely on and
that are relying on you in some sense
and the realization that you're part of
a bigger community that sort of step in
maturity that that growing up process
because otherwise the entire formula is
just going to fall apart yeah
no it's so true I mean you can take you
can take the content and shove it down
someone's throat you can make them sit
in the chair but if if they're mentally
sort of teleporting to a different place
and like you said the the motivation is
there just because it's harder to
quantify doesn't make it any less
important exactly and that's why here
especially on this facility you know we
say that time and again what we're
trying to do here on this facility is
we're trying to we're trying to create
change but from the inside out rather
than outside in because you can throw so
many programs that people just like you
said so much curriculum that you know
half of it probably won't stick if that
so it's it's a process it's an internal
process it's an individual process
because you know just like out there in
society everyone in here even though
there are some commonalities everyone's
different they've been through different
experiences that have led them to be who
they are so it's it's hard work but it
works you know giving a person hope
giving a person purpose especially here
we've we've been able to kind of track
the progress of individuals who actually
participate in our rehabilitative
programs educational programs just like
right now I can let you know I can tell
you that if you participate in a program
the inmates that participate in the
program that person is three times less
likely to receive a rules violation
report then someone who doesn't so it
definitely does change something and if
you look at the people who have as I
think Jason maybe you're mentioning some
people you can deliver the sermon too
right I mean you you communicate with
and then they fall off the rails and
that other people you work on for a year
you may be suspect they won't actually
take to it than they do
are there any patterns that you guys
have seen in terms of say what what
people fail to understand or pay
attention to that leads them to fall off
the rails so any anything that really
sticks out as a pattern where you're
like man like damn it I said like I
should have seen it because we've seen
this 17 times before or 200 times before
I mean I don't know how many people you
guys are communicating with because this
is what do you fifteen hundred people or
something like that this we have in this
facility we can get up to 1,000 about
1,000 but
averages at about 900 you know give or
take
as far as Pat I mean from my money and I
can't speak for you guys right I mean
everybody is really different and that's
kind of the reason at least for me I'm
even if a guy lets me down 17 times out
of 18 that 18 time it might just click
because I mean there are there are
commonalities usually the the impetus to
change is something like an event where
his family shows up I've seen that a lot
but some people there's like another
group of people that I think just
eventually they hit this point where
they're just tired and they just have
this realization one late night and
they're just sitting there and they say
I can't do this anymore and if you
happen to show up at that moment I think
you can lead them back into the light
but if you're not there then in there
then you probably missed your window so
I'm not sure that it's like
commonalities in circumstances so much
as it's these different circumstances
lead to change and if you're lucky to
get there you get there you know because
it really is a time and place thing at
least in my experience I haven't
personally identified any you know hard
patterns I can't say that the times when
I felt like it was certain to sink in is
if I was dealing with the guy who was
constantly entertaining the wrong
conversations and the wrong company on
the yard and you you can tell well you
know and then suddenly I had this
conversation with them and out of
nowhere it's really like a mature
conversation and he's talking about
wanting something different and he's
just talking to me about it and then the
next time I see him he's actually acting
on it that's a good indication that he's
heading in the right direction and then
it from there I think one of the things
we've tried to implement his repeated
exposure you know going back to that guy
going back to him and just work on him
encouraging him and hoping that he stays
along on the right path you know so I
have a question for you just because
you're you're mentioning you and your
brother coming and people knew you guys
were coming and that you had some
stature within this gang that you want
sparked up no no this is a sir I mean
I'm really curious about this because
I've known people who have
time in prison some very very close
friends of mine and people have had all
sorts of different types of unhealthy
coping behaviors and but at a given
point in time in their life some of
those behaviors like served a purpose
for them or they thought it did right to
escape from something or to survive
something and what what I'm curious -
and sometimes within that it's like you
could throw it all out but maybe there's
like a kernel of something that you
develop that can be applied in a good
way right so what I'm really curious
about it's like you were
sounds like had some type of leadership
position or you were somewhat high in
the the pyramid and this gang is there
anything that you were good at then that
has translated to you being better at
having these types of conversations or
recruiting people - you have recruiting
is the wrong word but converting people
to look at things differently do you
think there's any common ground there
networking networking no I'm good at
networking and I'm generally good at
people and interacting with them
generally not always there's no one no
one communicates perfectly all the time
right right but that's just one of the
you know one of my strong suits yeah
what do you think and maybe these I mean
these guys could comment on it also but
like and maybe it's easier for the
outside looking in but what makes you
good at what are some of the skills that
make you or approaches that make you
better than most is I can tell you what
makes Jason really so one of the things
about Jason right and I knew of Jason
right I never knew Jason until here and
now I I know Jason but I knew of Jason
before one of the things about Jason was
that he was true to his word he had
integrity right I'll give him that
now what his word was at the time you
know what that meant you know was I'm
gonna do something he's gonna do it
right that that he's brought that with
him though he has a very strong sense of
integrity and the values have changed
with it right so the thing about Jason
is if he says he's going to show
go up to chat with you if he's gonna
show up to help you out if he's gonna
show up to give you a pep talk right
he'll not only show up he'll probably
give you a day at a time and then be up
all night long if he missed it and
beating himself up about it and then
drag one of us along with him to make
sure he gets into the building to talk
to that guy the next day first
opportunity right and that's something
that I think he was kind of known for
before and now he's being known for it
again in a very good way because the new
Jason is in my opinion a market
improvement very very disciplined very
dependent yes so the ability to keep
promises yeah but the content of those
promises has changed so where would you
guys like to be say three years from now
so I actually have the opportunity
towards the end of the year to transfer
out to an mcrp which is a male community
re-entry program and what that is is I
would basically serve the remainder of
my term in a facility on the streets
wearing an ankle monitor and where I'll
have the opportunity to actually gain
employment work and save towards that
day when I'm actually paroled but in the
meantime we are we actually started a
podcast here on our facility current
valley 180 I thought that's what we were
doing right now that's what I thought
too we podcast it was supposed to so you
know in the knee with this first year
coming up we we plan at least to kind of
use that platform to not only show the
guys in here what it's like
transitioning back out to society
step-by-step but also kind of show
society what it's like being in here and
transitioning out into into the
community for me at least I want to show
the guy in here I want to show the guys
look this is what I did while I was
incarcerated while I was still behind
the fence behind the wall and this is
where I am now this these are the
struggles these are difficulties the
challenges that I'm facing so even
though you're you can prepare yourself
as much as you can it there are still
going to be some challenges so you
should prepare
absolutely so hopefully we were able to
do that through the podcast and I you
know that in the next three years I I
see myself heavily involved in some sort
of organization that gives back to this
particular community for sure thank you
um well currently I'm serving life
without parole so I just hope that
wherever I am at let's say a law changes
and I'm somehow miraculously you know
released a society then I hope to be
doing something good with rehabilitation
in either way if I'm still incarcerated
I'm hoping to be doing something that's
meaningful towards rehabilitation and
the rehabilitation effort what do you
what do you personally find most
meaningful I mean this is a really
important concept right I mean it's
really really important because I think
as you guys have noted it's like without
the without a purpose without the
meaning it's very difficult to to
survive as a human in any environment
and I think particularly in an
environment like this so what what keeps
you going and what would you if say
three years from now let's say you're
still inside what would make you look
back with some pride on the the three
years well
again anytime that you see the light go
off for the guy who's been struggling
the guy who is where I was yeah right
and he starts taking control or more
responsibility for his life and starts
learning tools to flourish and lead a
stable and healthy life I think that's a
win and if we can continue to get better
and better at our process of approaching
it and helping more and more people
that's that's purpose for me so it's a
good purpose in here sir I think so what
what are there any particular tools
certainly defy me and we're familiar
with define have a high opinion of the
fisa are there any other tools that you
found helpful to sort of as a this isn't
the best term but like a gateway drug if
you're trying to you know if you're
trying to get somebody who's maybe not
open and then they have that dark night
of the soul or their family visits and
there's a window and you want to offer
them one thing to kind of nudge them
towards a brighter path is there any do
you have any favorites or anything
that's particularly effective that you
found well the most the thing that's I
think been most most effective for me
has been asking the right questions so
that they can get to the right answers
and so if you're asking the right
inquiry and Brad mentioned pastor Krantz
earlier he has a method of when we take
a position on something he asked his
questions to where our position is
either exposed for being vulnerable or
being solid and I think that if you can
do that in the right way to people then
they are forced to come to their own
conclusions about whether or not they're
coming from their own the right starting
place or not and so whether that's a
tool or a technique yeah to me that's
been a really effective thing any any
any questions you could share or hey I
don't want to keep you on the spot like
anybody can answer this but like are
there any particular questions that you
guys use I obsess over questions because
I really think that whether it's
interacting with someone else or
interacting with yourself right
ask yourself the right questions with
you guys are helping them to do so the
pastor your chaplain Quran sees a
military man
all right so he looks at things from
that viewpoint a lot when it comes to
developing a an idea so we go to him you
know the idea of ferry lands on the
shoulder and gives us some crackpot idea
and we go in there and we say hey we got
this really great idea let's do X Y Z
and he'll start running it through sort
of a there will be the practical
questions they'll be the purpose-driven
questions they'll be you know who's
gonna run it where are you gonna get the
resources who's gonna staff this what's
the idea and then it'll kind of segue
into what are you trying to do what's
the point is what you're doing tackling
a symptom is what you're doing tackling
the problem is what you're not he'll
really get into I mean it's a
multi-level like systematic tear down a
few times we've surprised him but he
also I think what you're also getting
with Jason is also getting at is the
sort of self leadership model too right
so anytime something pops up you should
be asking yourself two questions two so
that you know where you stand otherwise
it's too easy to knock you down
so it's twofold you have to have asked
yourself two questions then once you
have the idea in mind then you need to
ask the questions about the idea and
that if it stands up to both those
stress tests I think you're pretty good
shape at least considering a lot of the
other stuff that goes on sometimes and
for me it's it's it's a lot simpler
really when it comes down to it I ask
myself and I ask others is it the right
thing to do
absent the environment the situation is
it the right thing to do and that's
basically what it boils down to you know
with me it's you know it's is what I'm
about to do the right thing is it is it
right for me is it right for everyone
else involved and that's kind of the
question that I always come up you know
and ask somebody when I see they're
getting ready to stray or they're
getting ready to make the wrong
decisions it's is it the right is it the
right thing to do and if they think that
it is and I question along like why do
you think that's the right thing and I
just kind of try to lead them through
that you know those logical steps
explain to me why you think putting that
metal in that guy is the right thing to
do because he called you a name it
doesn't make sense at the end of the day
and it's it's it's it's very very basic
but people forget to ask that question
sometimes well let me jump in on that
because this is
you were talking about it's all relative
rights if we get into like moral
relativism yeah one can almost argue
that whatever they want to do is right
right right given whatever story or
narrative they've built up for
themselves right so you had it was two
counts of armed robbery what I was
convicted for yes yeah okay maybe longer
but that's the official yeah at the time
well how at the time why did you why did
how would you've explained why you were
doing those things I don't I I could
never justify what I did but not now but
like at the time how it was it was just
a haze a cloud I was drinking heavily I
was using I was using drugs heavily I
like I said before gravitated back to
you know individuals that I used to I
used to hang out with that I used to run
with a gang yeah yeah and you know I
just kind of I just reverted back to old
ways that I had left behind and you know
my judgment was was very clouded and I I
just kind of went with the flow which is
what a lot of guys doing here they just
go with the flow they assimilate this
environment they suck it up and because
it's prison everything every excuse
you'll hear here it's is you you're
almost always here it's prison because
it's a prison because it's prison well
just because it's prison it doesn't make
it right and you know back then that's
that's what it was I I was just you know
I wasn't in my right mind no clear
judgment and so your judgment is seems
clear now what I'd love to hear from
from any of you guys is how you
recovered from slipping or relapsing or
when you've had the temptation what
you've said to yourselves right because
whether like I know people who are drug
addicts or former drug addicts
alcoholics my best friend growing up
unfortunately died of an overdose it's
like I I have not a lot of first-hand
experience but I've watched even with
let's just say on a very maybe mundane
level people
listening to this they have behaviors
and they try to change the behavior and
maybe they succeed for a while and then
they slip and maybe they slip and they
stay slipped for a long time or not but
like you guys seem pretty far on the
other side at this point but could you
talk about any times when you've either
slipped and then had to fix you know had
to come back or have the temptation to
slip do we have I leave I think we got a
bunch of time I think I got a I got a I
got a sticky note here that says the bus
broke down and we have a delay so their
misfortune is our good fortune I'm
afraid for them but so I I I lead by
example yeah so you know when I when I
feel when you know when the anger seems
to get the best of me I always think you
know if I lead by example what's that
what's that gonna say to you know all
the other guys and like I said it's it's
it's teamwork here you know with team
I always try to keep that in mind
really right so you're setting an
example whether it's good or bad exactly
and you know just not too long ago I
lost my cool and it was it was kind of
embarrassing you know yeah we have we
have we've one of your hands when you're
men laughing here so yeah tell us let's
let's if we could talk about it let's so
talk about the details so I'm you know
I'm I'm not now known as very
level-headed you know I keep my cool
because I've kind of learned to do that
yeah but you know here in prison we have
all sorts of personalities all sorts of
you know people with issues and whatnot
and one of the worse happen to move in
next door to me and look I'm programmer
man I like getting out to my programs on
time because you know half the time I'm
standing in front of that room making
sure the guys are you know heading in
the direction they need a head in and
you know this particular individual
decided to hold his tray because he he
felt he didn't get enough food and
obviously that turns into a problem
because oh he has holds this tray so he
doesn't release his food he doesn't he
doesn't give up his tray through the
port which means and now he has
something solid that could be used as a
weapon and obviously that's a safety
concern so for the
I'm being they kind of they kind of
close that section down you know pending
that issue being resolved and that made
me very upset but what made me even more
upset was that when they try to reason
with him a you know and told him look if
you continue doing this you're gonna
mess up the program for everybody else
and the guy started yelling expletives
out the door and basically cust every
buddy out and Here I am standing next
door in full blues waiting to come out
to run this program and this guy's over
here crying about not having enough food
and I kind of lost it and he ended up
giving up the tray and you know we had
some very unpleasant exchanges and I was
pumped up and and I was really really
upset and I show up to this to the group
and these guys are looking at me like
what what the hell happened to you and
it it was it was yeah it was it was bad
I was getting you know I felt
emotionally I was ready to go there yeah
right and but you know I'd like to cross
the line yeah and and then I you know
took you know took took some deep
breaths and I told myself you know what
you have to practice what you preach man
and I've done it before I've never
allowed myself to go that far and I had
to humble myself you know when I came
back in I went up to the guys door fully
expecting that door to open by the way
and I apologized him and I said look man
I don't know what the issue was if you
didn't get enough food do you need do
you need some soup turns out the guy
didn't have anything in his cell so
maybe he was hungry he was kind of a big
guy so you know I had to humble myself
apologize and kind of you know practice
that effective communication that we
always try to teach others here and it
worked the situation was de-escalated
and you know the next morning good
morning buddy so I obviously I still
keep kept an eye on them for the next
week because you know you never know
right but um
it turned out well and it's really it's
just about practicing what I preach at
the end of the day you know and and
again leading you know leading through
example and I can't how would that look
if the guy who's preaching you know
effective communication and resolving
your conflict in other ways other than
the physical way how would it look if I
got into a fight you know in the dayroom
because you know the guy called me this
and called me that and and I went there
it just wouldn't work yeah we have the
accountability yeah absolutely
thank you yeah you guys I would repeat a
lot of what in said I think that at this
point we've made a lot of public
statements about where we stand on these
types of issues so if we slip up on it
it's it's a pretty big hit the one thing
secondly for me personally I have to
always ask myself what's the outcome
here like how does this end
once it starts and so it's just trying
to avoid the situation from the get-go
now regarding a scrape of like a violent
nature or something you can't you you
you can't possibly take in all the
variables that come with that like
anything could happen in any given time
but I think that one thing I've tried to
keep in mind is that every act that I
take I'm trying to reduce the
possibility of that so every interaction
I'm trying to keep it or it doesn't even
go in that direction regarding substance
abuse I've had a problem with that in
the past and so again I've had people
that are close to me that have a severe
drug problem and it's created a lot of
anguish for me and at this point I think
I don't know I've created enough mental
leverage to stay away from it but if I
ever am tempted again it comes back to
what's my outcome here and what are the
public statements I've made how much of
a hypocrite will that make me you know
so I just stay away from that period
thank you yeah man let's see I whereas
there's the soft skill like there's the
effective communication way of doing
things and then there's sort of like my
way which is not that all the time
although I think I'm getting a little
better so I I snap at people fairly
regularly and have to go up afterwards
and they're like hey my bad I suck right
as far as I've never particularly had a
substance abuse problem myself yeah and
that's just an example right if there
are many different ways yeah slip I I
have an arguing problem and there are
times when I get into that sort of
concrete thinking thing and
even if I know I'm wrong I'm still gonna
argue my point I mean that's led to some
beefs before although I'm trying to not
do that anymore and that's where I'm
kind of picking up from these two guys
over here how does how does your process
or day change when you're trying not to
do it right so what do you do - I might
a decrease the likelihood you know I
find that when I think before I say
things it tends to work a lot better and
I know it sounds like kind of silly but
that's I haven't often done that in the
past although I have now so as long as I
have sort of a mental checklist to run
through and you know ask myself
questions as we go am I thinking about
this clearly do I understand what he's
saying is he are we clear on the terms
if we clarified what the heck were
actually talking a pause on the response
yeah exactly so as long as I take a
breath before opening my mouth which is
when I've usually hit in trouble
incidents on the yard kind of thing I
mean there there's been times where
there was the guy who clocked me in the
face one day on yard and I had to walk
away from it so let's dig into this so
what do you write in the news shorty why
you punch you in the face and I don't
know how much of this will have to be
cut out or whatever it's always edited
later there was an incident that took
place back in the locational class where
a gentleman had gotten heated and
somebody had to step in between it and
stop him and this incident led to a
conversation later on right with him
because well the guy who had gotten
heated had hit the guy who stepped in
between him and the guy who had gotten
hit which was another one of our pioneer
newsletter guys another reporter another
editor or madden and editor so he had
taken the hit and walked away and we
applauded that we said hey look now you
de-escalated it you you humbled yourself
you took the hit great job and now you
have to remember in prison if you get
hit and you don't hit back that's a bad
thing according to prison staff that's
precedent somebody somebody had said
well first you get hit in the face next
thing you know people are just coming up
and stealing your store
your store is canteen you know your your
hygiene your food and I had written this
piece about yes because that's what
we're gonna have we're gonna have roving
gangs of Marauders hijacking people and
stagecoach robberies for their store and
I'd kind of made light of it well the
gentleman who had gotten heated way back
in the beginning somehow interpreted
this as hey I was telling people to beat
him up on yard and steal his store so he
saw me a yard when I was out there
reporting on a football tournament or a
soccer tournament and took a swing and
he got me and I had just public I wanted
to get him did my I was seeing red my
hackles were up but I was telling myself
I was like dude you just wrote this
thing about it's okay to walk away from
taking a hit don't worry about it you're
not a [ __ ] right and I had done this
whole thing and this guy cracked me I'm
standing there and I had to take a
breath and be like hey we're not doing
this right here we're adults and I had
to turn around and walk away right and
everybody saw it and I was under I was
getting the blues for a while but then
slowly people were like yeah man don't
worry about that guy it's what's the
blues meaning you and I was just getting
there were some people that were coming
up and you know ribbing me and saying
some pretty pretty hurtful things man
but that's okay I'm used to that so so
how did you how did you feel after that
were you proud that you did that where
you're like man I should have ripped
that [ __ ] guy's face off no I was
like I felt bad that I had actually that
I wrote something that he had interpret
I should have gone and talked to him
before and I should have been like hey
dude we're gonna write an article about
something that happened involving you
and I should have been like is this cool
and I didn't yeah and that was my
screw-up and that made me feel bad and I
actually went back and I had talked to
the guy a few times and asked him if he
wanted to subscribe to the paper and
that probably wasn't smart I thought I
was giving him a peace offering he just
started kicking the door and yelling at
me so I had to walk away but I yeah I
felt bad that I had I felt I had handled
it badly
yeah I'd walked away but I had allowed a
situation to happen where this guy was
mad enough to hit me and that was where
I screwed up so I managed to not turn it
into a big deal
but I still effed up in there somehow
where would you like to be in say three
years time I mean if like three years
from now looking back you're like yeah I
did a really good job or I'm happy with
my progress it would need dampen I can
look at the yard I'm on three years from
now and 51% of the people on that yard I
could be like yes these are grown-up
mature adults and I had some small part
in that if some program I helped run or
come up with her bring to the yard or
some sort of stats that we had done to
figure then I'd be like yeah I did a
good job because everything is to that
end for me is making people kind of
realize their maturity fists of 51% just
meaning the majority yeah I want a
saturation rate that's you know
fifty-one percent then I know more our
product is the success so many different
directions I can go with all this the
first thing I probably should at least
check off because I know some people
listening to be like wait they have a
podcast so this is yes welcome to the
current Valley 180 podcast we're here
with Tim Ferriss thank you for having me
gentlemen how how did that come to be
and how do you guys record it and what
do you talk about I mean you can Abby so
do you do you have you have gear that
you have a room do you how does how does
a podcast cut but does it only get
distributed among the people at the
prison it is it more widely distributed
so the leadership here is very
progressive when CDCR
said we're gonna head more towards you
know rehabilitation the administration
the leadership really took that
direction at heart and I'm following it
absolutely you know the idea came about
I think there there's one there's
another podcast downtown San Quentin a
lower level much lower level facility
and but you know the things that they
talk about there and not you know
talking smack about them it's more you
know average day daily occurrences on
prison you're type deal here where I
think work we're creating we're
establishing more than just you know
talking about canteen talking about the
sports on the yard we're we're really
trying to highlight that rehabilitate
rehabilitation
and you know we were approached by the
administration if we would be interested
in doing something like that and we
jumped at it it turns out that this this
this institution has a media room which
it looks very much like a TV studio they
have all the equipment and it's just
kind of just kind of sits there because
they have no other use for it so you
know they've allowed us to use that room
for our podcasts we've been able to
interview our warden which here is the
first time that has happened you know
inmates actually interview their warden
on the podcast and we were able to
interview the CEO founder of défi
ventures for example and you know we
have a long list of people and now we've
interviewed you so oh yeah welcome me
actually yes ask me anything you want a
takes take some responsibility off of my
hands which I like but first let me ask
it following up on something that I kind
of pass by is it is this widely
available or is it only for people in
the facilities if this will be it yeah
it will be once we record our finish our
third one I believe it will be
downloadable on iTunes I think it sounds
great there's actually two versions of
it here because like I said there's
video cameras it's like a TV studio
there will be a like a video podcast
version of it available throughout the
institution so that all the facilities
here can can watch it and hear it and
then out there for the public it'll be
what I would I believe just strictly
audio podcast to iTunes yeah and you
guys are welcome to use this audio may
now I'm happy to give you guys the audio
too but that'll I get a question I
wanted I wanted to ask you yeah far away
what compelled you to come into a level
for maximum security prison and sit down
with us do you ask all these questions I
I think that it's very common whether
it's inside or outside for people to
separate between us and them or me and
others and when I look at for instance
some of the people I grew up with were
my best friends like I mentioned one
died of a fentanyl overdose others have
been imprisoned
and just like you were saying there's
this sometimes this almost magical
positive window when someone sees their
family or has this dark night of the
soul and there's an opportunity for
growth there are also these windows that
open which are opportunities to make
really terrible decisions and
circumstances I'm not saying you don't
have personal responsibility we're all
responsible but at the same time I think
it's I think it is wildly unreasonable
for people to think that they could
never find themselves in a position if
their life had been different if the if
their surroundings and friends had been
different where they would have made
terrible decisions they could have
landed them in a place like this and so
I think that my hope in coming here was
a to just learn about a new environment
and to get to meet people here honestly
I mean I just I'm very interested in
learning as much as I can about like how
what what this human nature looked like
inside the walls and not because these
humans are necessarily intrinsically
different from the humans outside
they've had they have very different
stories like what does it look like when
like yeah you guys had mentioned when
everything is intensified and magnified
you know does that tell us perhaps
something about ourselves more broadly
speaking right and also to not to say
that everyone here should be completely
forgiven of all the you know in some
cases terrible things that that they've
done to other people but that I do think
it's possible to have empathy for the
humanity in each and every person while
still holding them accountable and
that's that's I think that's one of our
main goals on our podcast is look we're
not trying to justify anyone's actions
anyone who's here you know mistakes were
clearly made but at the end of the day
we want people out there to realize that
people in here are just people yeah
we're humans you know we have that label
prisoner convict
and people sometimes tend to associate
who we are strictly on the crime that we
committed that maybe that bad day maybe
that bad decision maybe a series of bad
decisions but at the end of the day
we're human like I've moved I'm here
because I committed a crime and but I've
moved past that it's I'm obviously
reminded every day when I wake up and
I'm still in prison but I've been able
to forgive myself and really worked on
myself in order to someday gain that
forgiveness from my victims because
there are victims and you know I for me
at least that's that's what we want to
communicate out there look we're just
people anyone can make mistakes sure
there's degrees of mistakes but you know
it's it's tough it's tough sometimes
when you watch the shows on TVs and you
hear the narrative about prisoners and
and it's just always all you know all
just a negative yeah and and the other
you know another reason that I'm here is
you know with with defy and really want
to chat with you guys is that I'm
fascinated by why people change whether
it's for the better or for the worse
what is that moment what is that
conversation what is the chaplain say to
you or ask you right or what happens in
the shoe I'm really interested in these
tipping points for people and like to
study them because if you study them and
you can then figure out like alright
this particular tool works really well
and it seems to work and you spot some
type a turn I don't think that if we
assume that human nature is human nature
which I I suppose it's a bit of it like
a tautology but in the sense the people
inside are not that different from
people outside I think there's a lot to
be learned in here they could also be
applied outside of here right and I look
not that I like the fact that everything
is intensified here but it's it's in a
way very similar I've spoken with
Sebastian Junger who was a war
well it's considered by many to be a war
journalist but he's been deployed
overseas and his his best friend was
killed overseas with a because it was a
mortar round horrible tragedy and he's
seen many people killed and in war even
the you also see the certain aspects of
human nature that are just amplified
right and I think that gives you an
opportunity to see things that you might
not otherwise see and learn things you
might not otherwise learn so but the
fact that you guys have made made a
series of bad decisions that have made a
series of good decisions is very
interesting to me right so that's part
of the reason some of the reasons I'm
here yeah could I ask you a question
yeah absolutely
all right so one of the things that you
do as you were saying you're trying to
basically break it down they're trying
to figure out what it is that makes a
person tick right so do you have go to
questions are you trying to get to the
thought process are you trying to get to
what is it that you're looking for when
you're asking questions what process are
you going through yeah usually I am
following my own curiosity
so if if something if someone has
experienced any type of sudden change
I'm very interested in why that change
took place so I'll explore that I might
ask someone if you look back say at your
business over the last 5-10 years you
know were there any specific decisions
you made that you view in retrospect is
really critical or was there anything
you said no to that you were tempted to
say yes to that made all the difference
it was there something you were told you
had to do that everyone told you you
should do that you decided not to do was
there anything like that I like to
explore the good decisions but I also
really like to explore how people deal
with hardship and failure and darkness
so I've really tried to when I'm talking
to anyone no matter how successful they
may be I mean if I'm interviewing
Richard Branson or interviewing it
really doesn't matter like any type of
Icahn who might be thought of as this
perfect superstar I know they're not no
one's perfect and so I'll I will ask
them you know rather than just going
through the highlight reel we'll talk
about the highlights but I'll say like
can you could you take us back people
may listen to this and think that you've
got it all figured out
and that you haven't had your tough
times I could you take us to a tough
time or a period that you suffered from
depression or where you thought it was
all over and walk us through what you
said to yourself walk us through who
helped you and how they helped you how
did you get out of that funk I'm very
interested in that because I think those
are the that is when some of the most
critical decisions are made and it's
like if everything's lining up it's
really easy to be supportive of someone
else or supportive of yourself but when
things start going sideways when maybe
you slip maybe you relapse maybe who
knows you're paying too much attention
to your business and you're not paying
enough attention to your kids and your
kids make some really terrible decisions
it's like all right how do you we're all
gonna [ __ ] up it's like all right how do
you how do you then respond to that [ __ ]
up is more interesting than the question
have you [ __ ] up because the answer is
obviously yes the more interesting
question to me is like alright you
[ __ ] up now what happens and so
certainly in a different context but you
know I've beaten myself hop horribly in
my whole life I've had a very sort of
mixed relationship with myself and have
had been very very brutal with myself
just in terms of self-talk for the
majority of my life and I've only in the
last few years realized how unproductive
counterproductive that can be and so the
way and now externally if you were
watching me respond to a mistake it
might look the same as it did five years
ago but what's going on in my head is
very different does that make sense yeah
and so what I try to do then if I'm
interviewing someone is to ask them to
help me step into their head to see
what's going on behind the scenes right
or if they're afraid when they're most
nervous right if they're if they're a
championship fighter and they're getting
ready for the biggest fight of their
life like
they saying in their head as they're
walking out to the Octagon mm-hmm months
of training and like their entire career
is on the line and they could they could
have their head caved in like what are
they actually saying and can their own
head when they're listening to their
music walking out the these are the
types of questions that I've been
exploring more and more in the last few
years because I think that you can you
can learn from a real fighter like say
you know Tim Kennedy also a Green Beret
sniper I mean just an incredible guy you
can take lessons from him and apply to
business you can take lessons from
business and apply it to military in
some cases you can take lessons from
chess and apply it to working with
people in the art I'm sure in some cases
and vice versa
perhaps so usually I'm digging for the
internal process and trying to find
phrases or questions or concepts that
can be applied to a lot of different
things okay
that's very often what I'm what I'm
looking for yeah yeah that that's that'd
be my first stab at it okay something
like that and also the unit to dig out
the humanity in someone so it's to
encourage people to be vulnerable when
they can be or to like push to a point
where they're at least a little
uncomfortable I think that's when
interesting things happen not in the
sense of pushing yourself closer to say
a redline situation not not pushing in
that direction but you know I remember
interviewing this woman named Renee
Brown who's a researcher and she she
studied a lot related to shame and
vulnerability and related topics and she
said something to me that a really big
impact she said we we often I'm
paraphrasing but she said very often we
we think that we need to develop trust
with someone and then we can be
vulnerable and she said but very often
it's the opposite way around you have to
be vulnerable first before
someone will trust you and that really
stuck with me and in any case but but
I'm trying to find some of the
connective tissue and these
commonalities that can apply anywhere
and it's like if humans humans which by
and large I think it's certainly the
case and like whether you go to the
middle of nowhere and the jungles of
Borneo or you're in New York City or
you're in here or you're anywhere else
like the the same type of pain the same
need for purpose and meaning like it's
it's all there it's it's universal so I
I try to tease out hopefully things that
people can apply in any of those
contexts thank you yeah of course
well let's see you know I'm struggling
with I think this is a pretty natural
place to start to maybe wrap up a bit
but do you guys have anything that you
would like to ask or say to people who
are listening maybe not ask but as I
said before earlier my change came
through a really education really opened
my eyes I credit wise I have enough
college credits or I have the equal
amount of credits that someone halfway
through their masters would have but I I
can't achieve that because there is no
funding for post-secondary four-year
graduate degree levels so you know I'm
hoping that some legislation will gain
some traction that would give the
opportunity for individuals in our
circumstances to you know apply
themselves and earn you know higher
degrees
I would just say I guess it's kind of an
ask it would be something like you know
please don't write us off in prison
we've made some really really bad
choices
absolutely and we are responsible and we
are accountable for those and nothing
can take them back but that doesn't mean
that we can't change and do better and I
think a lot of times from what you see
on TV what you hear about most often
hard time lockup shows like that it's
kind of painted in light that there's no
hope for people in here and that's
really not the case we see it I hope
that you come to see it I hope people
listening will hear it and just don't
give up on people inside prison if I
could say anything to anyone out there
it would be that I find myself now in a
place where I actually have meaning in
my life and I feel like I'm bringing
value to other people but that's mostly
because of my community in here and
because of my family and friends on the
streets who never gave up so for anybody
who has someone in their life that's
struggling I would just say don't give
up on them hold them accountable but
continue to give them hope and try to
provide them tools and opportunities to
where they can make a change and start
making some good decisions because you
just never know who that person can
really become so just don't give up
thank you guys thank you thank you yeah
I mean on the inside or the outside
right I think those are good rules good
recommendations and it's it's
I mean I consider a real privilege to
share time with you guys because I mean
if I think about it right I mean you
have the opportunity potentially it's
like if you build up a to get to that
51% potentially right and beyond but if
you have if you develop this your own
program of sorts and you have your
approach to helping people develop this
meaning in this hope and also tilt just
slightly in the positive direction in a
more positive direction doesn't have to
mean they become mother Teresa overnight
which is pretty unlikely just like one
degree better right that one degree it's
like you start off here and you you if
you change your position
walking say one or five degrees in a
different direction
like you walk ten feet it doesn't seem
like that's that far away you walk a
hundred feet okay now now it's quite a
bit of a distance away and then you walk
a few miles now it's completely
different destinations right so that
initial change can make it make a huge
difference ultimately and and it strikes
me that like well after you guys have
left this place you could leave a legacy
of people who continue to do that and
potentially right so that's the goal
right so you kind of like senior class
teaches the junior class teaches a
sophomore class and that I mean that's a
really meaningful legacy so long as
there's no alumni coming back the
graduation with no right well guys I
really appreciate you taking the time
and I certainly wish you all the best
with everything that you're working to
build you know inside yourselves and
outside thank you keep it up with the
podcast thank you for coming on the
current valley 180 podcast we're your
hosts good luck on your podcast yeah
thank you it'll take off one day you
could be like us with tens of hours of
experience yeah a little bit out there
now that you got the big interview out
of the way that's right that's what's
been in the room is gone so uh I think
we should get back to the back to the
excitement across the yard so
you guys want to give your names more
time Jason haulin Ian via Toro would you
forget first I'm sorry I have to
disclose right my root my name is yes is
Gillian but it's so strange and odd that
everyone just calls me Ian god it's
Gillian via Toro but it's Ian via Torah
and I'm Brandon Minard all right
gentlemen thank you so much and keep it
up thank you too
hey guys this is Tim again just a few
more things before you take off number
one this is five bullet Friday do you
want to get a short email from me would
you enjoy getting a short email from me
every Friday event provides a little
morsel of fun before the weekend and
five bullet Friday's a very short email
where I share the coolest things I've
found or that I've been pondering over
the week that could include favorite new
albums that I've discovered it could
include gizmos and gadgets and all sorts
of weird [ __ ] that I've somehow dug up
in the the world of the esoteric as I do
it could include favorite articles that
I've read and that I've shared with my
close friends for instance and it's very
short it's just a little tiny bite of
goodness before you head off for the
weekend so if you want to receive that
check it out just go to 4-hour workweek
dot-com
that's 4-hour workweek calm I'll a spell
out and just drop in your email and you
will get the very next one and if you
sign up I hope you enjoy it
this episode is brought to you by
business Wars people always ask me what
podcasts I listen to and the truth is
not many because given all my other
projects I don't have a ton of extra
bandwidth but one new addition is
business warriors from the podcast
network wondering human history has seen
hundreds upon hundreds of epic Wars of
course and often they're between nations
but some wars are waged between large
corporations are between startups and a
large incumbents business wars which
have been listening to did you right
into the middle of these battles that
are waged for control of your wallet and
your attention
ranging from say the wars between
Netflix and blockbuster or Nike and
Adidas to rivals and small businesses
across the country struggling to survive
in a cutthroat
these stories really feel like dramatic
thrillers have been very impressed by
the sound design also which I didn't
think I would care about but it makes a
huge huge difference and just to give me
an idea of what you might discover did
you know that blockbuster was actually
catching up with Netflix until corporate
raider Carl Icahn got involved and that
episode is a fantastic one it's called
sudden death it's the first episode in a
multi-part a series that looks at
Blockbuster and Netflix which I'm
particularly interested in because it's
not just two businesses in a stagnant
industry with stagnant technology
there's a lot of different factors that
come into play or did you know or do you
know what Marvel did to really get ahead
of its much larger competitor DC Comics
great interest to me since I was a comic
book nerd and collected comics when I
was a kid
or how sneakers went from athletic work
and everyday wear this series explores
all of that and more it's hosted by
David Brown a former anchor of
marketplace and it is an immersive sound
design experience not just some type of
sterile business review that shares the
untold and very real stories of what
went on behind the scenes with the
leaders investors executives that led
them to either new heights or to roof
sometimes
somewhere in between you can search for
business Wars on Apple podcasts wherever
you're listening to this episode right
now or ahead to Wonder EFM for slash Tim
that's wo and ER y FM forward slash him
to find business Worth's a great show
and I do not say that lightly and I
might suggest start with sudden death
Netflix vs. blockbuster this episode is
brought to you by helix sleep last year
I committed to making sleep a top
priority trying to fix onset insomnia or
continuing to fix that depth of sleep
quality of sleep I tracked a lot I
tested a lot and I revisited really
everything from the daily routine to the
surfaces I slept on playing with the
chili pad whatever and when I moved to
Austin I got all new beds including
mattresses from helix working with the
world's leading sleep expert certainly
some of them helix sleep develop
mattresses personalized to your
preferences and
style to make sure that you can have the
best say possible without costing
thousands upon thousands of dollars
helix sleep has recently added a new
layer customized sleep with the helix
pillow the all new pillows are fully
adjustable so you can achieve perfect
comfort regardless of a sleep position
or body type or if you're a shifty type
like me I move around quite a bit when I
sleep just take their simple two to
three minutes sleep quiz to get started
and that will help ensure that they can
build a mattress for a pillow that you
will love new mattress
whatever this bespoke mattress is that
you arrive at will get to you within a
week and the shipping is completely free
you can try the mattress for 100 nights
and if you're not completely happy
they'll pick it up and offer a full
refund I tested that weave on policy
because I test all of these sponsors and
kick the tires a lot we tested it and
they came through on making sure that we
got ultimately the right mattress for my
body type to personalize your sleep
experience visit helix sleep comm /u Tim
and you'll receive up to 125 dollars off
your mattress order that's helix sleep
hey lis sleep comm forward slash Tim for
up to one hundred twenty five dollars
off your
[Applause]